and starts off this hour in Columbia
South Carolina hi Ann how are you I'm
doing something thank you good how can I
help I don't have a situation with a
daughter that has we have just recently
in the last three weeks found out has
embezzled approximately 80 thousand
dollars from our businesses we have net
stress from 2014 the beginning of the
you know these first few months 2013 and
we still haven't been in 2012 we haven't
gone back to 2011 yes oh right how old
is this girl 28 what was she was her
position with your firm she's still in
the position she's a manager and why is
she still in the position to be honest
with you
we need her for right now we have
implemented changes where as my husband
says the hemorrhaging has stopped there
is no way you know we just had we had no
idea but he's implemented changes where
it cannot it cannot be done now but
until we get somebody to replace her we
absolutely have to have her for right
now and that's my question I mean that's
you know we're taking it bit by bit
but I mean I don't even know what to do
other than I mean we do need her in that
position for right now and what was your
question of me for right now I think my
question is twofold
number one is it's something that should
be prosecuted
number two is it is their help in all
your helpers that you have out there is
their help for people that have an inner
core problem with that I don't even know
how to you know if
she's she said she's interested in
getting help but I don't even know who
to send her to where's the money well
she has not indicated she has not done I
honestly think that it's just as I look
back I think it's a Shopaholic to the
extreme because there's nothing
extravagant that you can see at all
other than tons and tons and tons of
clothes choose jewelry you know stuff
like that
she's single not now are we married and
you guys own a hundred percent of the
business yes sir
I I just I I can't imagine the
heartbreak that you're facing um and I
don't know what we would do in that
situation I if you can absorb the
financial blow I don't think I would
prosecute criminally but it would
probably be contingent upon some very
extreme actions on her part and I have
to tell you I think you're absolutely
ridiculous for leaving her in the
building one more minute I don't care
how much you think you need her you are
completely completely codependent if you
think you can drive a thief in the
building you know I got the very first
thing that should have been done is she
should have been her desk but it's
cleaned out and she should have been
sent home and with the understanding
that we're going to decide whether we're
going to criminally prosecute you on
this and that's going to be based on
your level of repentance which is going
to be based on you telling us where
every dime of this money went and
getting a bunch of it back right quick
because some of it's probably still in
her account somewhere and and you know
she hasn't even told you what she did
with the money I mean my god do you
people not talk about anything
she stole $80,000 from you I would have
been all up in her business right I I
agree I agree how can you possibly think
you leave this person in the building
and that's not a choice that I can make
the loans that is
choice that my husband has to make and
that was his choice right now
yeah and it's a bad choice he's a bad
leader he's a weak leader and he's going
to lose more than the $80,000 he's going
to lose the respect of his entire team
and he's probably going to end up losing
revenue and lost customers as well
because this kind of weakness in
leadership is a disease that will spread
through an organization and he's going
to have to stand up and he's got to man
up
I know his little girl broke his heart I
get that but the first thing he's got to
do is get her out of the building you
would never keep an employee ten seconds
after they did embezzlement from you not
ten seconds if they steal a roll of
toilet paper I'm not keeping them ten
seconds there our thief now that's the
employee part of it and then you go over
and say okay my daughter now has been
accused of a crime and now I've got to
deal with my daughter that's a separate
issue but we're gonna deal with her from
home not from the office and your
husband desperately needs to step up
into this it's not a matter being angry
about it it's a matter of wisdom and
lack of weakness versus strength I mean
this is not you're like sending out the
signal this is okay by leaving her in
the building it's just unbelievable what
you're telling your team and and you
know here's the thing
your team probably knew some of this was
going on depending on how big the team
is they probably smelled a rat
um and now how you deal with that is
going to dictate your all's future with
these businesses so I have I have my
son-in-law works on our team one of my
daughters runs our family foundation my
other daughter works on our team and I
can tell you with 100% certainty they
would be out of the building
instantaneously they'd be gone if they
stole 80,000 bucks that day they would
go home and then I would decide other
things that are harder decisions so
whether I'm going to criminally
prosecute my own kid I don't think I
would I'll be honest with you I think
that's where the dad would come in
rather than the leader but this
organization cannot absorb the blow of
that level of nepotism and yours can't
either that's just sad it's so
heartbreaking it's just I can't me I
can't breathe
I'm just thinking about you know if
Rachel or Denise or our
Winston or somebody I don't know I don't
know I mean it would just rip the heart
out of my chest and so and crush it and
just stomp on it I mean what kind of
psychopath steals from their parents but
they do and this girl has deep
psychological problems this represents
an unbelievable level of narcissism and
other pathologies that that only a
therapist is going to be able to outline
for you she's got to get some help I
mean that this is a broken messed-up
person oh how sad to face that with your
own kid it's tough enough for small
businesses go through embezzlement and
just the betrayal and the heartbreak of
somebody you trusted it was on your team
but it's your daughter
I can't even imagine oh and I'm so sorry
for y'all but for goodness sakes take
action for goodness sakes this is the
Dave Ramsey show
you